smiling through the storm the Prime
Minister put in on a brave face after a
forced policy u-turn
Chancellor is slow to approach the
lectern to explain away a budget
reversal that came quicker than anyone
expected what a day
it has been tough
but we need to focus on the job in hand
delivering an economic plan to room in a
conference which at times felt flat
defending his tax cuts and still a sense
of determination we are aiming for two
and a half percent annual Trend growth
we've done it before and we can do it
again we will show that our plan is
sound
that it is credible and that it will
increase growth that is our pledge to
the people of this country but policies
to achieve that already marred in
controversy this a Chancellor feeling
the Heat
I know the plan put forward only 10
years days ago has caused a little
turbulence I get it I get it uh we are
listening and have listened listening
but pressing on too we will get Britain
moving we will deliver lower taxes for
you and your family and we will grow our
economy I know we can achieve that goal
with grit with drive and with
determination we can meet the challenges
of this new era
a thumbs up from his cabinet but is it
enough
[Applause]
was a mistake to introduce the top rate
of tax the only one we saw from the
chancellor just then was a plan for
growth that'll get our country moving
increase wages create new jobs and
ultimately fund Public Services it was a
positive optimistic vision for our
country that we can all get behind
but it wasn't what he said inside the
hall that mattered the most to many here
but what came earlier a massive U-turn
made not out of choice but necessity
it's a recognition of political reality
the overwhelming reaction had been
unsympathetic and governments have to
deal with political reality that
governments
um can't march into too strong ahead
wind ultimately
opposition from the party within cabinet
and the public blowing this pm and
Conference off course but the change in
Direction a Time taken well I think it's
good news I think is what the people
wanted if you're in a hole stop digging
I'm disappointed that we've had to do
this because we shouldn't have got here
in the first place if you're going to
U-turn you should U-turn quickly and I
think we're in a much better place now
than we were 24 hours ago Mr Gove would
you just indulge me for a second you
must be 24 hours ago it was this man
calling on the government to make the
reversal no escaping the impact former
cabinet ministers can have
clubbing together to make a change so I
think in in government and in um you
know political life it's one thing to
say you know I'm tough the ladies not to
returning as the stature once said and
those are the things there's another
thing to understand that you must take
the country with you and of course
critically in the case of politicians
you must take your own side with you
taking the country with you important
always in politics and particularly here
in the Chancellor's own constituency
this was the U-turn I suppose that makes
them look better but it's not going to
help people yeah People Like Us it shows
that they don't really know where to go
I think it's good that they're reversing
it but at the same time they shouldn't
have had to be put under pressure in
order to do it I think you've got egg on
his face now and I don't think there's
any coming back from that
a chancellor who insists his is a
credible economic plan but who
credibility trying to bridge divides
with the public and his party but is
there any way back Beth Rigby Sky News
in Birmingham